y de hecho la mayor parte de esos malos tratos
proviene de cuidadores o de familiares.
Esta es Vicky,
Vicky puso una verja de hierro en la puerta de su dormitorio
y se convirtió en una prisionera en su propia casa,
por temor a su sobrino, que se adueñó de su casa para vender droga.
Esta es Mary.
Mary tuvo en sus manos una cámara de vídeo
por primera vez en su vida a los 65 años,
y pidió a Vicky y a otras 99 personas mayores,
víctimas de malos tratos, que contaran sus historias ante la cámara.
Yo soy holandesa,
y en Holanda estamos obsesionados con la verdad.
Cuando eres un niño, eso es genial,
porque siempre te acabas saliendo con la tuya,
en plan "Sí, mamá, fui yo quien se fumó los puros".
(Risas)
Pero creo que es por esto que he dedicado mi vida a promover
los vídeos de los ciudadanos que expongan la violación de los derechos humanos,
porque creo en el poder del vídeo para mostrar verdades irrefutables.
Y mi organización, "WITNESS",
ayudó a usar los vídeos del Congo
para ayudar a condenar y enviar a prisión al infame caudillo militar Thomas Lubanga.
Y los vídeos que Mary grabó,
nosotros enseñamos a Mary y a otros defensores de causas justas,
a que se aseguraran de que las historias de maltrato a mayores
lleguen a los legisladores,
y estas historias ayudaron a convencer a los legisladores
a aprobar leyes fundamentales que protegen a los mayores en EE. UU.
Así que pienso,
miles de millones de personas tienen esta herramienta tan potente en sus manos.
Es una cámara.
¿Por qué no somos un grupo de testigos locales más influyente,
como Mary y Bukeni?
¿Por qué este mayor número de vídeos
no se traduce en más derechos y más justicia?
Y creo que es porque ser testigo es duro.
Dirán que su historia es mentira,
su vídeo se perderá en un mar de imágenes,
no creerán su historia e irán a por Ud.
Y, ¿cómo ayudamos a los testigos?
En Oaxaca, México,
el Movimiento Magisterial organizó una manifestación
después de que el presidente impusiera unas reformas muy poco democráticas.
La Policía Federal acudió en autobuses y disparó a los manifestantes.
Al menos siete personas murieron y muchos otros resultaron heridos.
Las imágenes del tiroteo circularon
y el Gobierno Mexicano hizo lo que siempre hace.
Dio su versión de los hechos,
acusando a los medios independientes
de crear noticias falsas.
Dijeron: "Nosotros no estuvimos allí,
no fuimos nosotros los que dispararon,
eso nunca ocurrió".
Pero nosotros acabábamos de enseñar a activistas en México
a usar metadatos, de forma estratégica, con sus imágenes
Los metadatos son la información que las cámaras almacenan
mostrando la fecha, la localización,
la temperatura, el tiempo...
Pueden incluso mostrar la forma única de usar la cámara
cuando graban algo.
Así que las imágenes empezaron a circular,
y esta vez con información
totalmente confirmatoria.
Y el Gobierno Federal tuvo que retractarse.
La justicia aún está lejos
para la gente de Oaxaca,
pero sus historias, sus verdades, ya no se pueden seguir negando.
Así que empezamos a pensar:
¿Y si hubiera un "modo validación"?
¿Y si todo el mundo tuviera una cámara
y todas las plataformas tuvieran esa capacidad de validar información?
Así que desarrollamos
junto a unos desarrolladores de Android llamados "The Guardian Project",
una tecnología llamada "Proof Mode",
que empareja esos metadatos con las imágenes,
y valida el vídeo de cada uno.
Imaginen el aluvión de imágenes que vienen
de las cámaras de móvil de todo el mundo.
Imaginen que esa información fuera un poco más fiable,
el potencial que tendría para los periodistas,
para los investigadores y abogados
pro derechos humanos.
Así que empezamos a usar "Proof Mode" con nuestros compañeros en Brasil,
un grupo de medios de comunicación que se llama "Coletivo Papo Reto".
Brasil es un lugar duro con respecto a los derechos humanos.
La Policía de Brasil cada año mata a miles de personas.
La única vez que se investiga,
¿adivinan cuándo es?
Cuando hay un vídeo.
Edouardo de 17 años fue asesinado a plena luz del día
por la Policía de Río,
y miren lo que pasó después de que lo asesinaran.
Pusieron una pistola en la mano del chico,
y la dispararon dos veces
(Disparos)
para hacer creer que le dispararon en defensa propia.
La mujer que grabó esto fue una testigo muy valiente,
y tuvo que esconderse tras publicar su vídeo
porque temía por su vida.
Pero la gente graba y no va a parar de grabar.
Ahora estamos trabajando con grupos de medios de comunicación
para que los habitantes reciban
orientación y consejos vía WhatsApp
sobre cómo grabar de forma segura,
cómo subir un vídeo sin peligro,
o cómo grabar una escena de forma que sea válida como prueba.
Y aquí tenemos un caso inspirador,
de un grupo llamado "Mídia NINJA" de Brasil.
El hombre de la izquierda es un policía militar armado,
que se acerca a un manifestante.
Cuando protestas en Brasil, puedes acabar arrestado, o algo peor.
El policía dice al manifestante:
"Atención, te voy a cachear ahora mismo".
El manifestante es un activista que retransmite en directo.
Él lleva una pequeña cámara
Y le dice al policía militar: "Te estoy viendo,
y hay 5 mil personas que te están viendo conmigo".
Las tornas han cambiado.
Los testigos en la sombra, el público, importan.
Así que empezamos a pensar
¿Y si pudiéramos aprovechar ese poder,
el poder de los testigos en la sombra?
¿Y si pudiéramos usar su pericia, su posición de ventaja,
su solidaridad, sus habilidades
cuando una comunidad en el frente les necesita?
Y empezamos a desarrollar un proyecto llamado "Mobilize Us".
Porque entiendo que muchos de nosotros
queremos ayudar
y ofrecer nuestras habilidades y nuestra experiencia,
pero normalmente no estamos ahí cuando se agrede
a una comunidad en el frente, o a un individuo.
Y podría ser tan fácil con esta aplicación que hemos creado
que muestra al autor de los hechos al otro lado del móvil.
¿Cuánta gente le está viendo?
Ahora, imaginen que pudieran añadir planificación informática de tareas
a todo esto.
Imaginen que son una comunidad ante una redada contra los inmigrantes,
y que en ese mismo momento, lo retransmitís en directo.
Estarían creando cientos de testigos.
¿Cómo podría esto cambiar la situación?
Así que empezamos con este programa piloto con nuestros compañeros en Brasil.
Esta mujer se llama Camilla,
es la líder de una favela llamada "Favela Skol"
que fue capaz de atraer testigos,
mediante una retransmisión en directo
para ayudar con la traducción,
y con la distribución,
para ayudar a compartir su historia
después de que su comunidad fuera desahuciada
para hacer sitio para un evento olímpico muy lustroso el verano pasado.
Así que estamos hablando de testigos por una buena causa.
¿Pero qué pasa si es el autor el que está grabando?
¿Qué pasa si un transeúnte graba y no hace nada?
Esta es la historia de Chrissy.
Chrissy es una mujer transgénero
que entró en un McDonald´s en Maryland
para usar el baño de señoras.
Dos adolescentes le pegaron brutalmente por usar el baño de señoras,
y un empleado del MacDonald´s lo grabó con su teléfono móvil.
Y subió el vídeo,
que ha recibido
miles de comentarios racistas y homofóbicos.
Así que empezamos un proyecto llamado "Capturing Hate".
Tomamos una muestra muy pequeña de vídeos de testigos
que mostraban violencia contra transexuales y personas transgénero.
Buscamos dos palabras: "pelea de travelos" y "pelea de bolleras".
Y esos 329 videos alcanzaron la friolera
de casi 90 millones de visualizaciones,
y se siguen viendo ahora, mientras estamos en este teatro.
Y esos vídeos reciben cientos de miles de comentarios,
promoviendo más violencia y más odio.
Así que desarrollamos una metodología
que tomaba todas esas pruebas visuales no cuantificadas
y las convirtió en datos, convirtiendo los vídeos en datos,
y con esta herramienta,
las asociaciones LGBT pueden usar esa información
para luchar por sus derechos.
Y tomamos esos datos y los llevamos a Silicon Valley,
y les dijimos:
"¿Cómo es posible
que estos vídeos estén aún ahí
en un clima de odio
creando más odio,
llamando a más violencia,
cuando existen leyes que dicen:
"Este tipo de contenido no está permitido"?
Les pedimos que cambiaran su política.
Así que tengo fe;
fe en que podemos hacer que más vídeos signifiquen más derechos y más justicia.
Diez mil millones de visualizaciones en Snapchat
cada día.
¿Y si pudiéramos convertir a esta generación de Snapchat
en testigos efectivos y cívicos?
¿Y si se pudieran convertir en los Bukenis de esta nueva generación?
En la India las mujeres ya han empezado a usar filtros de Snapchat
para proteger su identidad cuando hablan de violencia doméstica.
[Me torturaban en casa y no me dejaban salir.
La verdad, la auténtica verdad, que no es apropiada para una TED Talk,
es que es duro luchar por los derechos humanos.
No hay una solución fácil para la violación de los derechos humanos.
Y no existe la tecnología
que pueda detener a los autores.
Pero por los supervivientes,
por las víctimas,
por las comunidades marginadas,
sus historias, su verdad, importan.
Y aquí es donde comienza la justicia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)